- I'll tell you why I'm really here.
I am a rapper,
(audience laughs)
and I run the comedy
clubs in New York and I.
- [audience member] Rap.
- Well, it would be strange
for me to say that if I wasn't,
and not build up to that, wouldn't it?
Just be like, "Are you
gonna rap for us then?"
Yes. I don't know if you
know how show business works.
(audience laughs)
It would be like if I
walked up and was like,
"I have three testicles",
(audience laughs)
obviously I would end the show
by we whipping out the extra testicles.
(audience laughs)
I am a rapper.
I do freestyle rap.
That's rap that's made up.
It's not written, it's not
prepared, it's not rehearsed.
It's improvised in the
moment. It's super fun.
And it's based on what you
guys want to hear a rap about.
So it's entirely directed by you.
So all you guys have to do,
and pay attention to the
little rules first, okay?
Think of a word or a topic or a phrase,
but try not to be boring.
Don't be like food or animals.
Don't say dog or pizza, it's super dull.
So I'm gonna give you like three seconds,
take your time while I sip my tea.
(audience laughs)
- [audience member] Kangaroo.
Kangaroo's an animal you dullard.
(audience laughs)
- [audience member] Foley catheter
- Wait did someone- what did you say?
- [audience member] Foley catheter.
- It's a wraparound catheter.
Where does it wrap around?
(audience laughs)
- (audience member) It
goes into your urethra
- Like, as it, like, as it,
do they like attach it to the thigh
and then in, or do you
mean like it wraps around
the penis and then into the urethra?
You're explaining it if
you've gone through this.
(audience laughs)
Just nodding like yeah.
So where did they attach
your Foley catheter?
(audience laughs)
Foley is the art of making
sound, so I don't understand.
Yeah. Foley artist are people
that make sound effects
for things, but presumably
it means something different.
- [audience Member] It's
the guy who thought of it.
- It's the guy who thought
of it. Cool. I love that.
The guy who's like "I think
we should put a thing inside a penis."
(audience laughs)
Yeah. We name that after you.
Oh shit.
(audience laughs)
I think that the guy who invented it,
I think Foley was the name
of the guy who bullied him.
I think that's-
(audience laughs)
So a Foley catheter, thank you.
I feel like we could have
gotten to the same point
if we just said catheter, but
I appreciate the extra learning experience
that I've gone through.
(audience laughs)
So we need four more suggestions
and let's make it quicker than that. So,
(audience laughs)
let's come over here.
What you guys wanna rap about?
- (audience member) Uterus
- Well, let's try and get our
minds out of the gutter and-
(audience laughs)
Okay, fine uterus. People
over there are like,
"No, if we're rapping about catheters,
we're rapping about uterus as well."
Uteri, utera, what's the plural?
- (audience member) Mayor de Blasio.
- Mayor de Blasio?
Okay, cool.
Great. Mayor de Blasio, uterus.
- (audience member) Area 51.
- Area 51.
What are you?
What's your opinion on area 51?
- (audience member) It exists.
- It- well, yeah, it's on,
it's on Google maps innit, but
(audience laughs)
would you take a job there?
- (audience member) No.
- No? Why not?
- (audience member) I like my job.
- What's your job?
- (audience member) No,
I'm not telling you.
- Why wouldn't you tell
me, what's wrong with that?
Unless your answer is comedy reviewer I,
(audience laughs)
then I don't mind.
I've been doing this the one time.
- (audience member) I'm
a management consultant.
- A management consultant?
Okay, cool.
A management consultant's
first day at Area 51.
That's that suggestion.
Mayor de Blasio, uterus, Foley catheter.
This side of the room,
you've been neglected.
What would you like a rap about?
- (audience member) Hurricane Ida.
- Hurricane Ida?
Was that- was the one that we,
we got the kind of drapes
off and it flooded,
but it did bad things down south?
But it was like a category
four when it hit, was it?
- (audience member) Five.
- It was five, it's five now?
It's still there?
(audience laughs)
It's going five but it looked
like the weirdest wave ever.
It's like off to school
on the back of the bus.
Okay. Well let's, let's
have some fun with this.
Oh, they put a little
connector on there for me.
Great. This is a freestyle
that is a rap made up-
someone over there saying this guy's sick?
That's very kind.
You've not even seen yet
unless you're like, oh no,
he's mentally deranged.
He thinks he can freestyle."
This is a freestyle.
It's a rap made up on
the spot based entirely
on those suggestions.
The suggestions are Hurricane
Ida, Foley catheter,
the uterus, Bill de Blasio
and a manager consultant's
first day Area 51.
Let's drop a little beat.
Let's have some nice fun.
(hiphop beat plays)
♪ Kick it off ♪
♪ I explain what I do then the Aussie ♪
♪ In the front rows like kangaroo ♪
♪ Can you rap about that mate ♪
♪ I'm like, no chill ♪
♪ It doesn't fit the bill,
but I still give the thrill ♪
♪ Maybe get a little catheter,
attach it to my dick ♪
♪ I say to the doctor ♪
♪ Can you put it in ♪
♪ He says, you'll feel a little prick ♪
♪ I need an anesthetic ♪
♪ A problem with my bladder ♪
♪ So, you know, I better get it ♪
♪ I'll be walking in there ♪
♪ And he told me, let me
explain how it works ♪
♪ This a Foley ♪
♪ I'm like, I don't care about the name ♪
♪ My bladder's inflamed ♪
♪ I just need it there
cause I'm feeling the pain ♪
♪ The sphincter in the
muscles can't contract ♪
♪ And so I'm pissing all
day and I start to laugh ♪
♪ The control that I need,
my mans at the side, like ♪
♪ Yes, correct details that
you provide. That's good ♪
♪ Yeah I'm feeling heaven sent ♪
♪ Lady at the back management
consult him saying ♪
♪ "I like my job, Chris ♪
♪ I wouldn't change" ♪
♪ But if you went to the desert ♪
♪ And looked at all the strange ♪
♪ UFOS and the things inside ♪
♪ What little insight you
could bring, provide ♪
♪ Walking in like don't worry ♪
♪ Yeah, my choice ♪
♪ Maybe work for BCG or Deloitte ♪
♪ Or even pay ♪
♪ What's all the cheering ♪
♪ You're like check out the
management consultant is here ♪
♪ And he stores them away
and uses them later ♪
♪ What would they have ♪
♪ An intergalactic potato or ♪
♪ Something like a little green man ♪
♪ You like, you need to downsize ♪
♪ That's the plan ♪
♪ Fire this alien, fire this SWAT team ♪
♪ Get out there ♪
♪ They start running in the team ♪
♪ The aliens like, "oh I'm new to this ♪
♪ I want to do a little
probe in the uterus" ♪
(audience erupts in laughter)
♪ Little baby, she says, "bye" ♪
♪ On her back I be like, "oh, oh my" ♪
♪ I inspect inside with a speculum ♪
♪ I ask her first, get consent ♪
♪ I'm respecting them ♪
(audience laughter)
♪ And that lot other people ♪
♪ Yes, I can't resist ♪
♪ You'll feel a little cold ♪
♪ I'm a gynecologist from Pluto ♪
♪ I'm looking in though ♪
♪ Oh, looking at the walls ♪
♪ All the shedding. It
goes every 28 days ♪
♪ I can see a after birth period ♪
♪ That would be called low key ♪
♪ low key like the Goddess of mischief ♪
♪ Never met bill ♪
♪ Yeah, I know he's the big chief ♪
♪ He be over there ♪
♪ Not Cuomo ♪
♪ That's a bad guy, touching
other ladies down low ♪
♪ Like the aliens ♪
(audience laughs)
♪ But B.D.B. he's the guy ♪
♪ Like, hey everyone, see me ♪
♪ Maybe when I die and I
depart from these model coils ♪
♪ They will name an airport after me ♪
♪ But probably not already got LaGuardia ♪
♪ Don't know what he does ♪
♪ Is he good, do you cheer
when he says things ♪
♪ And he's like, yeah, I'm in charge ♪
♪ Mayor of New York and avenue large ♪
♪ What does he do ♪
♪ Is he good ♪
♪ Does anyone know ♪
♪ He's got a nice cut band
sack here in the show ♪
♪ Like I'm shaking my head ♪
(audience laughter)
♪ Why? Cause I'm confused ♪
♪ What was the last thing that we choose ♪
♪ from you that we need to do ♪
- (audience member) Hurricane Ida.
♪ Ah, yes ♪
♪ Coming through people
like we are in distress ♪
♪ Oh, New York ♪
♪ We got the tail end ♪
♪ It happened in the final ♪
♪ Of the US open ♪
♪ People get their cars ♪
♪ They left them on the bridge ♪
♪ They were like, please expressway ♪
♪ I can't believe we did ♪
♪ Try and drive down
but wide at the mouth ♪
♪ You should pay more attention ♪
♪ To what happened down south ♪
♪ Like in Lake Charles
and in Baton Rouge ♪
♪ They had a much worse
time than you dude ♪
♪ But still admittedly,
it's not that strange ♪
♪ because unlike us, they
probably denied climate change ♪
(audience cheers)